Prof: Last time we heard
about some medical
considerations regarding
stereochemistry,
and we're going to just start
today with a little bit about
legal considerations about
stereochemistry.
First, the doctor gave a
disclosure last time about her
connections.
So I'll do the same thing.
I've served as a scientific
consultant or expert witness to
a number of pharmaceutical
companies, including Eisai;
which is how I knew about that
7389.
I take Lipitor,
and served as an expert witness
for a generic competitor in a
case involving the validity of a
Canadian Lipitor patent by
Pfizer.
And my only connection to
AstraZeneca and omeprazole is as
an occasional consumer of
Prilosec.
Okay?
This book here is very heavy.
It's about the stereochemistry
of organic compounds.
And interestingly,
it's from 1994;
so it's less than fifteen years
old;
and it's still the bible.
And only eight pages of it are
about biological properties,
and just one of those pages had
anything to do with legal
things;
which had to do,
incidentally,
with cocaine.
It turned out that somebody was
on trial for cocaine and the
defense had the idea that the
prosecution had not tested the
cocaine to see which enantiomer
it was, >
as to whether it was -- might
have been artificial;
because the enantiomer of
cocaine, there's no law against.
It also wouldn't work.
But anyhow, they hadn't tested
it.
So they thought they could get
their client off.
I didn't actually look up the
case to see whether they got off
or not.
But that's an interesting
stereochemical application.
But one that made a big
difference was the court
rejecting a suit about Nexium
marketing.
We saw last time,
and you did a problem for
today, about Nexium and whether
the advertising seemed
convincing to you;
or fair, for that matter.
There was a big suit about
that, and this -- in 2005 there
was a news report about that.
"A federal court in
Delaware dismissed a
class-action lawsuit"
alleging AstraZeneca has had
misleading marketing of Nexium
and thus added billions to
healthcare costs.
And the "district court
judge,
Sue Robinson,
rejected the suit brought by
the Pennsylvania Employee
Benefit Trust Fund on behalf of
entities that foot the bill in
healthcare plans.
According to the health plan
paying organizations,
the big difference between the
two drugs is not effectiveness,
but advertising."
(So you presumably looked at
some of this and have your own
opinion about that.)
"By selling doctors and
patients on the idea that
patented Nexium is better than
Prilosec,
which faced generic
competition, AstraZeneca was
able to preserve billions in
sales."
So, for example,
the year Nexium was introduced,
their advertising budget was
260 million dollars,
and in 2005 it had declined
slightly to 226 million dollars.
But the sales were 5.8 billion
dollars.
So the advertising was
negligible, compared to the cost
of advertising.
"Judge Robinson said the
courts should defer to the U.S.
FDA in weighing the differences
between drugs,
and that since the FDA cleared
Nexium's label,
the lawsuit could not
stand."
So that's interesting,
it shows the importance of the
FDA.
Okay, back to chemistry now.
In order to market Nexium,
the single enantiomer,
AstraZeneca had to,
of course, prepare it as a
single enantiomer,
which meant either resolution
-- so separation of the right
and the left-handed forms --
or else preparation of only the
one form,
the (S)-omeprazole.
I noticed that the doctor said
eeso-meprazole.
Maybe they all pronounce it
that way, but the reason it got
the name is because it's
S;
so I say esomeprazole.
So how are you going to do it?
Resolution.
You could do a Pasteur
conglomerate kind of thing.
You could make temporary
diastereomers and separate them,
perhaps by crystallization.
Or you could destroy one
enantiomer,
react the racemate with a
resolved chiral reagent that
would react with only one,
or maybe a catalyst that would
catalyze the destruction of only
one, like an enzyme.
Or you could do it nature's way
and prepare only one enantiomer,
either from a resolved chiral
starting material,
or using a resolved reagent or
catalyst.
And they tried all of these.
So let's look at it.
First, resolution of omeprazole
by chromatography.
So they had silica -- which is
what you use probably in your
chromatography -- but they
coated it with something that
was a single enantiomer.
Now how did they get something
solid that was a single
enantiomer that they could coat
it with?
They got it from nature.
It was cellulose;
trisphenylcarbamoylcellulose.
And they did this in 1990,
when they were looking forward
to the time that they'd lose
patent protection on the
racemate.
So there's cellulose and phenyl
isocyanate;
the thing with two double bonds
in a row there.
Now, what would make,
do you think,
phenyl isocyanate reactive?
Do you see any functional
groups there?
Any ideas?
Student:  A double bond
of carbonyl.
Prof: Okay,
carbonyl double bond.
Good.
And how about the cellulose?
What's going to make it
reactive?
Student: Hydroxyls.
Prof: Rick?
What makes cellulose reactive,
any functional groups?
Student:  It looks like
mostly hydroxy groups.
Prof: So unshared pairs
on oxygen.
Okay, so an unshared pair on
oxygen can attack the carbonyl.
Now, you could in fact use the
C-O or C-N double bond.
And, in fact,
we've seen this before.
This, remember,
is how urea got made,
from ammonia and the
corresponding acid.
This is just a phenyl derivate
of that acid.
So it does the same thing.
And, in fact,
you can do it with all the OHs
in the group.
So you put that carbamoyl
group, as it's called,
on all the oxygens.
So that is the chiral stuff
that was on the solid that the
chromatography was conducted
with.
Now, they weren't able to get
very much.
They did six injections with
chromatography,
and were able to get three 3 mg
of the dextrorotatory and 4 mg
of the levorotatory stuff
separated by the rate at which
they would go through this
chiral column.
Now that wasn't enough for any
kind of human testing or
anything.
You need 20 mg,
remember, for a human dose,
for just one dose.
But what they could do was
measure how fast racemization
was;
because obviously if the stuff
racemized immediately,
it would be useless to have a
single enantiomer.
So they found out that the
half-life for racemization was
an hour at 75°,
which they then extrapolated to
what it would be at a body
temperature to be 100 hours;
so plenty of time.
It's not going to racemize just
spontaneously.
So at least that was not a
trouble.
So this very first quick way of
resolving it allowed them to see
that it was maybe worthwhile
continuing.
Okay, then they tried
reversible formation of a
crystalline mandelate ester.
Now that red stuff there is
mandelic acid,
which is a natural substance.
So you have that as the pure
S enantiomer.
And now you want to react that
with the omeprazole,
with racemic omeprazole.
But you do it with an
intermediate compound,
formaldehyde,
such that the formaldehyde,
the carbonyl group,
gets attacked from both sides,
one at a time,
by the nitrogen on the
omeprazole and the oxygen on
mandelic acid,
to put a CH_2 group between
them.
And we'll talk about that a
lot, that kind of thing,
when we get onto the chemistry
of aldehydes and ketones.
But anyhow, they could do that.
Now they have what?
They have two things.
What's the stereochemical
relationship?
Because they had racemic
omeprazole they had reacted from
(S)-mandelic acid.
What are the two -- you have
two compounds,
what's their relationship?
Student:  Diastereomers.
Prof: Russell?
They're diastereomers.
So they're different.
So you can crystallize them
apart.
Okay, so they did that.
And then the important thing
was that it's a reversible
reaction.
So they could go back again,
adding water,
and get the omeprazole back,
after the separation.
And now they have both the
R and the S
versions of them;
both the d and l,
or the dextrorotatory and the
levorotatory forms of
omeprazole, in separate bottles.
And now they have hundreds of
milligrams.
So it's not enough to do a
large-scale test,
but they can do some biological
testing.
And with it,
they found that the R
was four times as active as the
S, in rats that they
studied.
But lo and behold,
when they got into humans,
it turned out it was reversed,
that the S was more
active than the R.
So that's why the drug is
(S)-omeprazole.
Okay but that's -- but you're
not going to do this to make
enough to sell to the public,
especially because you don't
want to throw away half the
material you make;
both because you're polluting
the environment and because
you're wasting the money you put
into making it.
So they developed a chiral
catalyst involving titanium.
So there's a titanium bonded to
four alcohols;
or actually one of them bridges
to another titanium.
But anyhow, you can do
something called ligand
exchange.
So the electrons in the bond go
onto the oxygen.
So you have RO- and Ti+;
you've broken the bond.
Now that goes away and a
different one can come in,
a different alcohol,
and form a new bond.
So that exchanges the ligands
by losing one and putting on
another one.
Okay?
Now you can do that trick with
diethyltartrate.
So two of the oxygens,
the alcohol oxygens of tartaric
acid,
can exchange for two of the
alcohols that are on the
titanium,
and you get this compound of
titanium.
Now what you really want is the
That's what's the catalyst.
So you can lose another RO- and
you get this Ti+.
And now's when the catalysis
begins, because you bring in a
peroxy compound,
a hydroperoxide.
So instead of an alcohol,
there are two oxygens there.
And that can do the same trick
and combine with the titanium.
So you have this compound.
But now you have a different
functional group there.
You have the O-O bond.
And what makes the O-O bond
reactive?
We've seen this before. Kevin?
Student:  The high
nuclear charge gives the low
LUMO.
Prof: And what is the
low LUMO?
Student:
Ïƒ*.
Prof: Right.
So Ïƒ* is going to
be reactive there.
Okay?
And you can bring in a sulfur
-- right?
-- with its unshared pairs,
and they'll react,
make a bond,
break a bond.
Right?
So you get the sulfur attached
to the oxygen,
and it's S+,
since it has used its electrons
to make that new bond.
Now, that thing can come off,
the same way the compound above
it did;
the RO came off,
the sulfur compound could come
off.
And that's the sulfoxide;
remember, that's the important
group in the
(S)-omeprazole;
that's what sets things going.
Okay, so we've got it.
And now that compound on the
lower left, the titanium
compound, is the same as the one
on the upper right.
So we've made a cycle. Okay?
So that means we can look at
the cycle this way,
a catalytic cycle.
We bring in ROO-.
It combines with the little
machine.
Then S comes in and RO- comes
out.
And then S double bond O comes
And you get the catalyst back
again.
You can start at the top and go
-- so you go round and round and
round and round,
and every time you have the
peroxide come in,
the sulfide come in,
the RO- comes out,
and the SO comes out.
So essentially the ROO gives
one of its Os,
the red one,
to the sulfur.
Right?
But it's catalyzed by this.
Now why is it important for
their purposes that this thing
be involved in catalysis?
We looked last time that you
can put an oxygen on sulfur,
just with peroxide.
You don't need the catalyst to
do that, although it's faster
with the catalyst.
Did they do it just to gain
speed, or can you see something
else?
What's special about the
catalyst?
Lucas?
Student:  Well it's one
enantiomer.
Prof: Pardon?
It's one enantiomer,
right?
It's a chiral oxidizing agent.
The peroxide alone would've
been an oxidizing agent,
could've done the trick.
But the chiral oxidizing agent
means that it will discriminate
between the two hands of the
product.
Right?
It could attack one of the
unshared pairs here,
or it could attack the other.
And those are enantiomers of
one another.
But when it's combined with
this thing,
that has tartaric acid on,
which makes it chiral and of
one hand,
then those are diastereomers,
when it attacks this one,
or when this one does the
attacking.
Right?
So they won't be 50:50.
Unfortunately, it was 50:50.
It just happened to be the same
rate.
So did they give up?
No, they started fiddling.
And one thing they did was to
add diisopropylethylamine.
Why?
Who knows? Right?
But they discovered that when
you do that, then you get what's
called 94% enantiomer excess.
That means the desired
enantiomer is there at 97%,
and there's 3% of the wrong
enantiomer.
Right?
So there's an excess of 94% of
the enantiomer you want.
So now all you do is
crystallize it,
and it gets purified.
You get rid of the 3%,
and you have the stuff you
want.
And now you can sell it to the
public as Nexium.
So that's the way you do it
practically, right?
When you want to make a lot of
stuff you make just one.
Okay, so that's what we're
going to say about
configuration.
And now we have one
"C"
to go.
We talked about composition,
of course, from the time of
Lavoisier;
about constitution from the
time of Couper and
Kekulé.
But then there are distinctions
based on this bonding model.
Note that constitution is
already involving the bonding
model.
But something beyond
constitution is how things are
arranged in space.
So configuration is obviously
also a question of the model
that you make for bonding,
and conformation,
which is the "C"
we haven't talked about yet.
And those last two are
stereoisomers,
because they have to do with
arrangement in space;
which constitution,
as you remember,
doesn't.
So the difference between
configuration and conformation,
both of which have to do with
arrangement in space,
is that the configuration,
you have to break bonds to go
from one isomer to another,
and in the conformation you
just rotate about single bonds
to get from one isomer to the
other.
And, in general,
it's hard to break bonds and
easier to rotate bonds.
So typically configurational
isomers last longer than
conformational isomers;
but not always,
there can be special cases.
Now all things that you call
isomers represent local energy
minima.
So the molecule can sit there
at that geometry -- and of
course it has to be vibrating,
at least zero-point vibration.
So the atoms are moving,
but they're in a well;
they stay in the same relative
locations, more or less,
right?
They vibrate in there.
But then they can get out of
that well and go to a completely
different well,
and vibrate there.
So not all the different phases
of vibration are considered
different molecules;
that would be way too much,
to call those all isomers of
one another.
Those are all one isomer,
and these are all another
isomer, but there's some barrier
to get from one to the other;
so you can have one or the
other.
And the barriers are typically
higher for configuration and
lower for conformation.
Okay, now we've seen that in
the nineteenth century
stereochemistry was qualitative.
It was a question of counting
isomers;
not measuring something but
just counting how many isomers
you could get.
Very qualitative, right?
But conformation,
which didn't come along until
much later,
which involves rotational
isomerism about single bonds,
is much more subtle,
and it requires quantitative
thought about equilibria,
rates and energies.
It's not just this qualitative
counting of isomers.
So notice that this
conformational analysis came
relatively late to the timeline
we're talking about.
All the other stuff we're
talking about happened before --
most of the other stuff,
with respect to structure --
happened before 1900.
But it was only in 1950 that
conformational analysis began,
and then twenty-five years
later that people started doing
significant,
what's called molecular
mechanics modeling,
treating molecules as if they
were springs and so on.
And we'll talk about that a
little bit later.
So remember there you are,
and we can trace your lineage
back to P.D. Bartlett at
Harvard, who was my Ph.D.
supervisor, and his Ph.D.
supervisor, J.B. Conant.
Now, those guys were involved
in a special flavor of organic
chemistry which influences you.
It's called physical-organic
chemistry.
It's interested not so much in
making new compounds as in why
compounds behave the way they
do.
So what you've suffered through
this semester is because of
these guys.
Right?
We talk much more about why
things work --
how bonding works,
how to recognize a functional
group --
than we do with memorizing
reactions that will get you from
here to there.
Okay, so Conant was one of the
founders of this discipline,
because he did a Ph.D.
with two advisors,
one of whom was a physical
chemist and one who was an
organic chemist.
So if we go back a little bit
here, you see the blue,
the organic chemist,
was Kohler, who we've talked
about, and the red was
T.W. Richards,
the physical chemist,
who himself studied with
Wilhelm Ostwald,
who together with van't Hoff
and Arrhenius --
these three guys here,
van't Hoff,
Ostwald and Arrhenius -- those
are the guys who founded
physical chemistry as a
discipline.
Okay?
So we have a lot more physical
chemistry in this course than
you normally would in an
elementary organic course.
Now, if you go a little bit
further in the family tree,
you get G.N. Lewis as well,
whom we've of course talked
about.
Now, in the late nineteenth
century,
when these guys were founding
physical chemistry,
organic chemists focused their
efforts on molecular structure,
on these things having to do
with configuration and
enantiomers and so on.
But physical chemists focused
on energy, sometimes to the
exclusion of structure.
In fact, Ostwald -- oh I forgot
to bring his book,
I was going to bring to show
you;
but I have a page from it here.
He wrote lots and lots of
books, Ostwald,
who's like your four times
great-chemical-grandfather,
or something.
This Principles of
Chemistry -- which he gave
the not too modest title An
Introduction to all Chemical
Textbooks.
So this is what,
if you read it,
then you were ready to read any
other chemical textbook.
So it was a general view,
in 1907.
And on page 421,
there's a very long footnote.
And if you look at a little bit
of this footnote,
it says: "Dalton,
who developed the law of
combining weights on the basis
of an hypothesis he had proposed
about the composition of matter
from atoms,
at first took hydrogen as
unity, since it had the smallest
'atomic weight',
i.e.,
combining weight."
And so there's the word 'atom'.
And that's the only place,
in 554 pages of this book,
that the word atom occurs.
It's in the subordinate clause
of a footnote,
because, at this time,
Ostwald didn't believe in
atoms.
He believed that
philosophically,
since you couldn't see them,
you shouldn't talk about them;
so you should do things that
you can deal with.
And energy was such a thing,
he thought.
So physical chemists,
these guys who founded physical
chemistry,
focused on -- of course,
van't Hoff is interesting
because he's the guy that had
the idea of the tetrahedral
carbon.
So he didn't sign off on this,
together with Ostwald.
But Ostwald was much more
influential,
he had a much bigger school of
students,
and so he was -- it was only
two years later that he finally
accepted the existence of atoms.
So I'm just drawing for you the
contrast between what organic
chemists were thinking about and
what physical chemists were.
And now, to deal with
confirmation,
we have to become a little
physical chemist to see the
influence of energy.
So here's the dedication of
Sterling Chemistry Lab in April
1923, and there's a group of
people that we'll look at.
And all of these guys here were
students of Ostwald.
So he had a very broad
influence.
The one there is
T.W. Richards;
got the first American Nobel
Prize in Chemistry.
Okay?
And he, remember is your
something-grandfather.
Okay?
So then Donnan,
the next guy -- well there's a
guy from Canada,
a guy from Britain,
and the guy on the left there
was a student of Richards,
so a grand-student of Ostwald;
with his cigar,
as he always had.
And this guy is Wilder
Bancroft, who was at Cornell,
and who founded and owned,
for that matter,
the Journal of
Physical Chemistry.
And he wrote an obituary of
Ostwald,
in 1933, in which he said:
"Ostwald's gift for
leadership showed itself in the
way his pupils regarded him all
through their lives.
They usually believed what
Ostwald said,
even when they knew he was not
right." Okay?
And no doubt atoms were what he
had in mind;
that Oswald didn't believe in
atoms, but his students still
believed in atoms.
Okay, but they all believed in
energy.
Now, did anybody walk past here
this morning?
You recognize this place?
Okay, you take a different path.
Okay, but have you noticed
what's off on the left there?
"Here Stood the House of
Josiah Williard Gibbs,
Class of 1858,
Professor of Mathematical
Physics."
So Yale has a really special
connection to energy.
There's Gibbs as a freshman,
and here he is in later life.
He spent his whole life here at
Yale, except for one year he
went to Germany.
So physical chemists were,
and still are,
quantitative about equilibrium
constants and rate constants.
So big K is an
equilibrium constant;
small k is a rate
constant.
And they're related to energy.
So you can call energy
E, or if you're more
particular you can call it
H, for enthalpy,
or G for Gibbs free
energy;
and entropy gets into the
argument, as we'll see in a few
lectures.
So energy determines what
can happen at
equilibrium;
that is, if you have this
stuff, is it possible
spontaneously to go to this
stuff?
If you have forever and ever
for it to happen,
is it conceivable that this
stuff will go to this stuff?
It can only happen if it's
downhill in energy,
in free energy.
Okay?
And the equilibrium constant is
determined by -- is related to
energy in this way.
And here's something that's
really handy,
and you'll impress subsequent
teachers and your roommates and
everyone else is you remember
this: that if you know the
change in energy,
in kilocalories per mole,
you can say what the
equilibrium constant is,
because it's 10^(-3/4 of
whatever that is).
So suppose the difference
between this and this is 4
kcal/mole.
What will the equilibrium
constant be?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: It'll be 1000;
10^(3/4 of 4);
3/4 of 4 is 3;
10^3 is 1000.
So the equilibrium constant is
going be 1000.
Now whether it's 1000 or 1/1000
depends on which way you're
going.
But obviously it's going to
favor the one downhill.
So you have to keep your
thinking cap on to get the right
direction.
But 10^(-3/4 of
Î”H),
or -- yes, 10^(-3/4) is the way
to do it.
Okay.
But you can also say something
about how fast it will go.
This is just whether it's
conceivable that it will go;
the big K.
The little k says how
fast.
Because rates -- this is an
approximation,
this isn't written on the
tablets by the angel or someone.
But for practical purposes,
for our purposes,
the rate in seconds -- that is,
how many per second -- is
10^13.
So that's very fast;
10^13^( )per second.
But then it gets cut down by
how big the energy barrier is
you have to get across.
Cutting down is exactly the
same kind of thing you have in
the big K,
10^(-3/4 Î”H).
So you could again -- that
energy is called activation
energy.
It's how high the barrier is
that you have to get over.
And you can use the same trick
of the 3/4ths.
So it's, the rate constant is
10^(13-(3/4 of whatever
the energy)).^( )So suppose you
had a fourty kilocalorie energy
barrier you had to get across;
suppose you had a forty
kilocalorie energy barrier you
had to get across.
Forty kilocalorie energy
barrier, right?
How fast would the rate
constant be?
Becky, why don't you help me?
So the barrier is 40 kcal that
you have to get across.
So now how am I going to plug
that in here?
Student:  10^13th.
Prof: Okay,
so 3/4ths of forty I need,
right?
So what's that?
Student:  Ten -- or
thirty.
Prof: Thirty.
Okay, so it's 10^(13-30).
Okay, what's thirteen minus
thirty?
Student:  Negative
twenty-seven.
Prof: Okay,
so it's 10^-27 per second.
Do you think that's very fast,
10^-27?
That's a pretty small number,
right?
So forget spontaneously,
at room temperature,
going over a barrier of 40
kcal/mole, for practical
purposes.
But you have this T here.
So if you increase the absolute
temperature, then you make that
forbidding factor smaller and
smaller and smaller,
up in the exponent.
So if you heat it up,
you can make the reaction go.
Okay, so anyhow,
that's really helpful,
to remember this 3/4ths trick.
Okay, now conformation involves
rotational isomerization about
single bonds.
So the question is,
how free is single bond
rotation?
Paternó
said it wasn't free at all;
I can count isomers that way.
I can have this isomer,
and I can have this isomer,
and I can have this isomer --
right?
-- for purposes of counting.
But van't Hoff says no,
don't count isomers like that.
Because why?
Why shouldn't you count isomers
like that?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Because they
rotate too easily,
right?
It's like that in his picture.
Right?
So you shouldn't count this and
this and this and this.
Okay?
Now, there are different kinds
of models, something like these,
and some of them you can rotate
easily, but not others.
Right?
Which one's realistic? Right?
Or this one you can rotate,
it's just not easy to rotate --
right?
-- it sticks,
Or this one,
remember, that Fischer used;
which is good because you can
bend it, for his purposes,
for drawing two-dimensional
Fischer projections.
But forget rotating that. Right?
It could vibrate,
but it can't -- you can't
rotate it, it'll always come
back.
Right?
So the question is,
which model is right?
Can you rotate or can't you
rotate, and how hard is it to
rotate?
Because that's going to
determine how fast these things
will be.
Okay, now notice that both of
these authors drew their
pictures with a conformation
which we call eclipsed.
Now eclipsed means these.
It means this,
that the ones on the top are
right over ones on the bottom.
Okay?
And the same is true in van't
Hoff's tetrahedra -- right?
-- right above the others.
Obviously you could rotate
60° on the top and
everything would be staggered,
not directly above.
Okay?
Notice, incidentally,
that from the exam we looked at
the Molecule of the Week,
for last week,
from the American Chemical
Society.
And notice how it's drawn.
Right?
It also is eclipsed.
This red one here is directly
opposite this red one here.
This acid group is directly
opposite that hydrogen,
and this acid group is directly
opposite that hydrogen;
it's eclipsed, right?
And here, this CO_2 is directly
above that CO_2;
it's eclipsed, right?
Now you need notation and names
to talk about these things.
And the projection that was
invented for this purpose was
invented by someone who sat in
the seat that some of you are
sitting in.
I don't which.
Maybe -- he probably,
in the course of his
undergraduate years and also
getting his Ph.D.,
he probably sat in most of the
seats in here;
or many of them anyhow.
But his name was Melvin Newman.
You see he graduated from Yale
in '29 and got his Ph.D.
in '32, and then he went to
Ohio State.
And he invented a way of
drawing conformations on paper.
So there are two carbons,
and the convention is,
for the Newman projection,
that you sight down the
carbon-carbon bond.
So I'm going to show this,
the rotation around this
central bond.
Okay?
So I look right along that
bond, and there's one carbon in
front and one carbon behind,
and each of them has three
things on it.
Okay?
So the one behind,
here, has three hydrogens,
and the one in front hides the
one behind.
Okay?
But it has three other groups
on it too.
Everybody see how he's doing
this;
that that shows this?
Well it shows it without the
methyl groups here.
Okay, and he calls that
staggered, right?
But you can also have them be
right on top of one another,
like this.
Right?
And that's called eclipsed.
And that's the way it was shown
on the previous slide by
Paternó,
by van't Hoff,
and by the ACS operative who
made the Molecule of the Week.
Okay?
Now that's not so convenient,
because you can't see the stuff
in back.
So sometimes people turn it a
little bit that way,
or sometimes they turn it a
little bit that way;
by which they don't mean that
it's not eclipsed,
they just mean I want to be
able to show both things.
Right?
Now that's very cumbersome,
and the reason you don't mind
that it's cumbersome is that
things are never eclipsed,
they're always staggered.
So all those previous pictures
were wrong, including the
Molecule of the Week,
because conformations tend to
be staggered,
not eclipsed.
Okay, but anyhow you can draw
them this way.
Okay, and that's just a
conventional way of drawing
something that's eclipsed;
because, as you can see,
it's not truly 100% eclipsed.
Okay?
Now, when you have substituents
on those things,
you can give different names to
different phases of rotation.
For example,
they could be exactly opposite
one another, like that;
which if this were a double
bond you would call
trans,
or E.
Right?
But for a single bond,
you look at it with a Newman
projection like this,
and it's called anti.
Right?
Or you can have it rotated like
this, and be what's called
gauche.
And I've never found out why
it's called gauche.
Right?
But notice something about that.
Is this, is it, anti, chiral;
is that conformation chiral,
or is it superimposable on it?
Is there a mirror?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Right,
there's a mirror right here.
Right?
So it's its own mirror image.
How about gauche, is it chiral;
is there a mirror here?
There's a twofold axis here.
If I rotate it like this,
if I had you close your eyes
and did that rotation,
you couldn't tell whether I
rotated it or not.
Right?
It's like a propeller.
But if I take another one like
this and make the mirror image
of this gauche one,
like this -- here,
right?
This is a mirror image.
Everybody see?
Right?
But I can't superimpose them.
If I superimpose the back
three, the front ones are not.
Right?
So these are chiral.
So, with respect to gauche,
we have enantiomers.
Right?
That one as well.
And one of them we call minus
and the other we call plus.
Okay?
And now if you have -- the
analog for eclipsed is that you
can have something that's fully
eclipsed,
like that, where the special
groups are right on top of one
another.
Or it can be like that. Right?
So and that can be one way or
the other;
and again it's twisted,
like a propeller would be.
And these are again cumbersome
things to draw,
with Newman projection.
But you don't worry about their
being cumbersome because you
don't have to draw them usually,
because they're not energy
minima, they're not isomers,
they're barriers between going
from one to another.
Okay?
But again, those would be minus
and plus.
And if you want to be really
pedantic and meet in a committee
of the Pure and Applied
Chemistry people,
the IUPAC, and decide precisely
what you're going to call
different things,
then you get together and you
scratch your head,
and for different rotations of
the thing in back,
with respect to the thing in
front,
you have these different
pedantic names:
synperiplanar is the one that
we call fully eclipsed;
and you can have anticlinal and
synclinal and synperiplanar,
and plus and minus,
and so on.
But you never do that really.
But it's there if you need it.
Okay, so there's a notation,
Newman projection,
and there's a nomenclature,
which can be sort of simple,
like on the previous slide,
or very complicated,
like this, that allows you to
discuss these things;
to draw and discuss them.
Now, but here's the practical
question.
Is the threefold barrier -- so
if you have ethane,
like this, and you rotate this,
the energy will go up and down;
the energies will be different
for different angles of
rotation.
But obviously there's a certain
symmetry, that this,
if it's all hydrogens,
will be the same energy as
this, will be the same energy as
this.
And for the eclipsed,
this will be the same as this,
will be the same as this.
Okay?
So there's a threefold barrier.
Now the question is -- two,
there are two questions.
How big is the barrier?
So are we going to be able to
have isomers?
And, what's the energy minimum?
Now let's just suppose,
together with van't Hoff and
Paternó
and the person who made the
Molecule of the Week,
that the lowest energy -- if we
plot energy versus phase of
rotation here --
that the lowest energy is
0°;
that's fully eclipsed,
like this.
Okay?
That's 0°.
And now we'll start turning it,
and the energy may go up,
when we go to a staggered,
and then down and then up,
down, up, down.
Right?
And then you're back where you
started, once you've gone
through 360°.
Or is there a big barrier?
Right?
Is the barrier small or big?
Now how can you tell?
Here's an interesting thing,
a way to tell,
right?
That if there's a big barrier,
then the things are going to be
quantized in it;
the energies are being
quantized.
But the energy is -- if the
barrier is very,
very small, then almost any
energy you have is above the
barrier, and so it's not
quantized.
Remember, when you get above a
barrier you can have energy,
any energy you want.
It's only when the thing is
bounded on both sides that the
wave function has to come down
and reach zero.
Okay?
So if the barrier is big,
the energy will only be certain
amounts, but if the energy's
very small, you can have any
energy you want.
And that you can tell.
That is, in fact,
how it was discovered how big
the barrier for rotation was,
was by measuring something
having to do with energy,
with heat.
Okay?
And here's -- so the question
is, is the energy quantized in
this triple minimum?
We've talked about double
minima.
This is actually a triple
minimum.
Okay, so they measured in 1936
the absorption of heat by
ethane, going down to a very,
very low temperature.
This starts at 150 Kelvin,
but I think they went further
than that.
So there's a thing called
entropy;
and we'll talk about that in
different terms,
a little bit -- in a week or
two, after vacation.
Okay?
Vacation.
>
Okay, so there's a thing called
heat capacity,
C_p, which is how much
heat you absorb.
So entropy is defined,
by people who do
thermodynamics,
in this way:
that you sum up,
or integrate,
starting from zero Kelvin --
remember Kelvin?
-- all the way up to whatever
temperature you're interested
in.
You sum up how much heat is
being absorbed;
so C_p times
temperature, that's how much
heat is being absorbed at each
temperature, as you go up.
As you raise the temperature,
more and more heat gets
absorbed.
But you always divide it by the
temperature, as you go up.
So if you absorb heat at very
low temperature,
that makes a much bigger
difference than absorbing the
same heat at high temperature,
in this quantity called entropy.
So don't worry about it,
except by this definition for
now.
And this is very technical and
not so very important to what
we're doing.
So don't get tied up in knots
about it.
But anyhow, if you have larger
quantized spacings,
then less heat gets absorbed --
and I'll show you that on the
next slide --
and the heat that gets absorbed
gets absorbed at a higher
temperature.
Right?
So both those factors mean that
the entropy,
at any given temperature,
is going to be smaller,
because you've absorbed less
stuff in the numerator,
and you've absorbed it at a
higher temperature;
so you have a bigger
denominator for all these
contributions.
Okay, so the results in 1936
were this.
If you're interested in what
the entropy of ethane is,
at 298 Kelvin,
it turns out experimentally --
that's what they did out at
Berkeley --
they found it was 54.8 plus or
minus 0.2 entropy units.
And then they calculated how
high that would be,
for different heights of this
threefold barrier,
and the quantization that's
involved.
And what they saw was that if
the barrier were zero,
that number,
instead of 54.8,
should be 56.4.
If the barrier were 0.3,
it should be 56.3.
If the barrier's 3.1,
it should be 54.6;
which is within experimental
error of the experiment.
Right?
So that showed that the barrier
was about 3 kcal/mole.
So it wasn't totally free
rotation.
It was just pretty fast.
So suppose the barrier had been
4 kcal/mole, instead of three;
just suppose it were four.
How fast -- what would the rate
constant be for the rotation?
So the barrier is 4 kcal/mole,
that you have to get over.
How do I deal with that? Sam?
Student:  It's this --
Prof: There's a trick,
right?
Student:  10 to the --
Prof: 10 to the minus --
Student:  -3/4.
So 3/4 times four is three.
Prof: Okay,
so it's going to be to the --
there's going to be a -3,
up in the exponent.
And what else is going to be in
the exponent?
Remember, for a rate?
Students:  Thirteen.
Prof: 10^13.
So it's 10^(13-3),
which is ten to the --
Student:  To the tenth.
Prof: 10^10 per second.
So it would take 10^-10th
seconds for it to rotate.
That's pretty darn easy,
at room temperature.
Right?
Pretty easy.
But not perfectly free,
and enough to make this
difference in the entropy.
Now, let me just see what time
it is;
okay, we have time to do this.
Okay, so we're now going to use
that big K,
equilibrium constant.
So suppose we have something
that has -- this rotor say --
that has a barrier of such that
the spacing between successive
levels is 1 kcal/mole.
Suppose it's a harmonic
oscillator.
We already did that.
The lowest zero-point level,
you got to have that energy,
and then 1 kcal above that,
1 kcal, 1 kcal.
Now what we're going to do is
see how much energy,
extra energy,
above zero-point,
is there at equilibrium,
at any given temperature.
So we have some stuff -- at
equilibrium there's going to be
stuff that has no extra energy,
zero-point, a certain amount.
But there'll be a certain
amount that has 1 kcal/mole,
that's in that first level.
Now how do I know how much is
in that first level,
at equilibrium?
How do I know the ratio of
what's in the top to what's in
the bottom, if the spacing is 1
kcal/mole?
Is there a way of doing that?
You don't have to do the
numbers, but tell me what
formula you would use,
to get the equilibrium
constant.
Katelyn, do you remember?
Sophie?
How do you get the big K;
how does it relate to energy?
Anybody remember?
We already did the hard one.
Eric?
Student:  10^-3/4ths.
Prof: 10^-3/4ths of one.
Okay.
That's at room temperature.
It's different at other
temperatures.
Okay, so we know how much
there's going to be -- what
fraction of the stuff,
of the stuff that's here,
is going to be one kilocalorie.
Ah, it's going to be 10^-3/4th,
of this;
so something like 1/10th of it.
Right?
10^-1 would be 1/10th. Okay?
And then there'll be stuff
here, and the amount here,
relative to the amount here --
this is what we're doing.
So that ratio,
the ratio of 0:1 is going to be
the same as the ratio of 1:2,
because that one is one
kilocalorie above this one.
And the same for the third to
the second, or the fourth to the
third.
So then we can sum all these
up, knowing the ratios,
and figure out what percentage
there is of each of these.
And it turns out that that
10^(-3/4) is 5.6.
So there's going to be 5.6
times as much here as there is
here;
5.6 times as much here as there
is here;
is here.
And if you translate that into
percentages, it'll be that
there's 81.9% here and
1/5.6,14.8% there and 2.7,
and 0.5%, and 0.1%.
But of course this stuff added
only -- this 14% added only 1
kcal/mole.
This one added two.
This one added three.
This one added four.
So you sum all those up and you
get how much energy -- how much
heat was absorbed.
This didn't absorb anything,
it's still in the lowest.
This absorbed a certain amount,
14.8 -- right?
-- .148, and then twice that,
0.027, and so on.
So you can sum it up and see
how much heat would've been
absorbed by the time you get out
there.
Now, if the spacing had been
very much smaller,
if the spacing had been 0.025
kcal/mole,
then we would've made -- how
much is there of this that's in
the lowest level;
how much has one unit, 0.025;
how much has 0.05,0.075,
and so on?
And we do exactly the same
trick;
although of course you need a
spreadsheet to do this with,
because it's tedious.
Right?
But you would get this.
And you see you absorb more
heat if you have smaller steps.
And now there's 4.2% here,
and 0.8% at exactly 1
kcal/mole.
But you have a lot of others in
here.
So 59% of the population is
halfway out to the one;
and then 33% is more or less
one;
and 6.6% is like that;
and so on.
So anyhow, you absorb more heat.
And you absorb it at lower
temperature too.
Right?
So both those things build up
the entropy.
So that one absorbs 364
kcal/mole more -- not
kilocalories,
small calories -- 364 more than
the other one.
And that is what gives that
entropy difference.
Okay, so that's how people knew
that there was a barrier to
rotation, was by measuring heat
capacity.
So we'll stop here,
and next time we'll address the
question of whether the --
now we know what the barrier
is, but we don't know what the
low energy form is,
whether it's eclipsed or
staggered.